India's Parliament has reinstated
leading opposition figure Rahul Gandhi
as an MP that's after the Supreme Court
suspended his defamation conviction
Gandhi was sentenced to two years in
prison for saying why do all thieves
have the surname Modi an apparent
reference to prime minister Narendra
Modi the Supreme Court said the sentence
was too severe the ruling allows him to
run in next year's general elections
well let's get more on this now we're
joined by Uday Chandra he's an assistant
professor of government at Georgetown
University in Qatar and he's joining us
from the Indian Capital New Delhi thank
you very much for your time so just
firstly how much of a victory is this
for one of India's leading opposition
figures being back in Parliament
but it's a good sign it shows that in an
election year the Judiciary is willing
to do something that the government may
not like and that suggests that there is
a somewhat leveling of the political
playing field uh in the nine months to
go for the elections yeah but you know I
I would I would be wary of reading too
much in to this decision okay so uh you
have mentioned that we're going into an
election year how does this board for
that opposition Alliance ahead of next
year's general election could it
invigorate efforts to unite the
opposition
I think so I think uh it's a very good
sign uh Rahul Gandhi uh may not have
Prime ministerial Ambitions of his own
but he can unite
um you know 20 or more parties that
would be in the opposition taking on
Prime Minister Modi and this is
definitely a confidence uh booster uh it
also matters that now Rahul Gandhi and
his party can attack uh the government
directly in Parliament rather than just
relying on um movements and activism
outside of it so I think in overall in
and outside of the house in the
legislature
um we are going to see a lot of pressure
on the government and it's really on the
back foot all right since Prime Minister
Modi came to power in 2014 the
government has been accused by the
opposition by human rights organizations
both inside India and international of
weakening institutions including the
Judiciary what do you think this ruling
tells us I know that you've said let's
not read too much into it but what does
it tell us about the country's highest
court
I think it suggests that there is a
period of uncertainty in India State
institutions no one really knows how the
elections next year would depend out
there's a lot of disillusionment with uh
nine and nine and a half years of the
Modi government
um there's economic distress there's um
social conflict mostly social and
religious conflict
um so there's it's it's a society in
disarray and those who are in the
bureaucracy in the Judiciary uh in state
institutions that matter
um might possibly have a change of heart
uh and might be and they might think
that there is some uncertainty over
whether this government will be able to
retain power or whether it will actually
uh end up losing to a United opposition
and how does a United opposition if in
fact they can stay United until the
election how do they capitalize on what
you're saying is a society in disarray
it is a government that has been plagued
by many challenges since Prime Mr Modi
came to power in 2014 and yet they have
won state election after election and in
fact the previous election too
yeah I think I think that there's a
formidable electoral machine uh with a
lot of money with a lot of data driven
uh um political activity
um that brings the government uh into
poor position every time there's an
election
um however in state elections especially
those over the past year uh we've
noticed that the government seems to be
struggling in the states uh so far we
haven't seen those struggles in a
national election
um and it will be very interesting to
see whether
um the national election is a kind of
aggregate of different state elections
where different parties take on
um the BJP
um one by one and that's really how the
Coalition uh would come together it
wouldn't be
um you know everyone taking on the BJP
in a single constituency or electoral
District it would involve a kind of um
divide and conquer approach interesting
that is Uday Chandra of Georgetown
University live in New Delhi thank you
for your time
thank you